on n'a pas cette première fin de semaine
pour la récolte des pommes une activité
sécurisante
en cet automne pas comme les autres
c'est une activité qui au moins on sait
qui on m ait quand même écarté il va on
ne peut pas être ensemble ça s'est super
bien passé dans le fond si on rentre
dans les bottes quoi que ce soit mais le
mas on se nettoie bien les mains ses
fans de façon telle que nos amis ont
quitté fille je veux c'est agréable
station de désinfection agrandissement
du magasin réduction du stationnement et
élargissement de la portion du verger
ouverte à l'autocueillette tout était
prêt pour accueillir les clients nous
autres on avait sous 50 dollars tout
comme les changements qu'on doit il
faire des panneaux des plus d'employés
aussi on m'a plus d'employés il espère
que les familles seront au rendez vous
après l'annulation de tous les groupes
scolaires qui déambulait habituellement
dans les vergers en septembre une
moyenne de 500 m
enfin par jour pendant au moins 30 jours
seule activité qui en main qui composent
cette année c'est une perte pour la
famille charbonneau fait la moitié de
son chiffre d'affaires avec la vente
directe de produits
l'autre portion est vendu aux grandes
chaînes d'alimentation grâce aux
travailleurs étrangers
la production s'annonce bonne cette
année malgré la sécheresse du printemps
qui laissait craindre le pire en est un
qui était plutôt en faisant avec le
manteau qu'on aurait la place à l'heure
est vraiment eu le qu'on a connus plat
semble faire la file pour l'inde un kiff
amarré le favori tient au québec les
pomiculteurs prévoit accueillir plus de
500 mille tonnes de pommes cette année
avant la coved 19 une belle fin de
semaine ensoleillée pouvait attirer
jusqu'à 6000 personnes au verger de
denis charbonneau cette année avec les
nouvelles normes sanitaires
on prévoit en accueillir la moitié mais
ce qui fait la différence entre une
bonne et une mauvaise saison pour le
pomiculteur c'est la météo
il s'y marie josée paquet comme
radio-canada mont saint grégoire